how's it going I'm here away and we're
gonna kick ass and triumph wait who's
rich today okay angry you're not doing
these a mess we don't know we're doing
that they don't your mouth I'm winning
yes I think yes yes okay flip you're
going down that face - points for
falling up when you get both bonus
points for doing cool tricks do it just
like I did who's yours one let's go away
great I always win we play this for
hours and what did you pass up the most
what is this
thanks game bank for me okay we
shouldn't spots that I know he's stuck
doing tricks now why does he suck so
much
did I win yes we're all gonna get stuck
here I can't even spot my guys
you're all help finish can I get a zero
or one fine I'll just go with the rabbit
maybe Ben no how about we all go rabbit
one to you I'm scared of taking anything
the yellow line okay
oh it's not crazy now no beat you all so
much
no no go so far yeah we just can't let
go off the script yeah I suck even
though wait that's what she said starts
messing up on the second rate so
hopefully we have a relationship why are
we last anyway you guys I went to pass
I told you you know double front flip
what up no see that you they don't teach
you that in school
I can't even spawn yeah okay
second I'll take it it's okay I think
it's whoever has proved a away okay my
guys not doing tricks man I'm happy
about this front flip on the front flips
you guys have to do flips every joke I
think you press a key to do tricks and
you get bonus points okay
oh you gotta do some tricks man yeah
yeah see that yeah yeah you're really
good you're good at this
like I know what he's bad at these well
we're all I'm gonna do so many tricks
this time okay straight over here
I just there's a button to do tricks
like my guy was doing flips no guys you
to press why you'd be the best trick one
trick I did one trick he won't start
this is out of control
yeah it's too addictive yeah I need more
of this adrenaline rush it's so amazing
how would you do it again seriously I
mean came by the house all right there's
two more races still chance to catch up
that's not gonna happen to me though
because now my god it's crazy is he
crazy ya know I don't know oh well I've
got immunity barking up it's crazy
screen to lose I'm gonna lose with style
baby
last race I don't think anyone can beat
sorry boys yeah why is really good they
actually infinitely when you first why
to train us so again no concentration
project is so much pressure I'm sorry
come on yeah so let's see how it goes
Zoe why thanks pretty [ __ ]
thank you for watching thumbs up if you
enjoyed and and your all party in your
face okay one two three
breakfast